paula in h tone texas what's up paula
hi doctor how are you i'm so good
how are you i've been better let me just
kind of tell you what's going on
let's do it bring it on what's going on
having problems in my marriage
um i'm 52 okay i've been married for
about six and a half years
both of our second marriages we've been
arguing
like constantly probably for the last
six weeks
probably just calmed down last week
what are you arguing about so
it's mainly about my dog
he hates my dog and he he doesn't want
me to get rid of him he says
but he's been threatening lately he said
he's gonna take him to the spca
he doesn't want you to get rid of him he
just wants him dead and gone so yeah
cool
exactly and that's like the main one of
the main things and we don't have deep
conversations
about the marriage about finances and
good times and bad times but
like the pet has really been uh
just coming up constantly and so i
go ahead go ahead and i just told him i
said if you
do that take him to the spca what do you
think is going to happen
to our marriage and he just said
well you'll you'll get over it oh he
called your bluff
yeah i was really yeah
i was just like okay so is this
is this these fights about this dog
is this dog a proxy war for
a marriage that's not communicating that
is not
having um good
connection that's not having lots of
good
um intimate moments that is not
um fully on the same page with your
finances and with where you guys want to
go as a couple
is the dog just where all this is
landing
or does your husband just hate dogs
i think he hates this dog because
initially i've had the dog
10 years okay i was not going to keep it
he long story short he was
he my sister wanted him she was living
with me and i said you need to take him
when you go but she couldn't and
i just decided to keep him and that was
before mary and after we got married he
thought i would get
a dog a dog and i said no i'm not going
to do that
so what keeps two grown adults
from going to have breakfast somewhere
you can even go to dinner for this
conversation
and saying we've got to deal with the
dog i don't like that the dog pees
everywhere i don't like the dog's hairs
everywhere i don't
like it's it sounds like um
sounds like two kids throwing crayons at
each other
and that's made me agree but you're one
of those kids and so
what is it about like the adult party
will he just refuse to engage you as an
adult
or is he saying i want to be an adult
and this dog is whatever getting hair
all over my clothes or we don't have
enough money to keep
feeding this dog or this dog reminds me
you got him with your last husband and i
don't like you
importing parts of your last life into
this new life i want to start fresh with
my new wife
i don't want to here's what i'm saying
paula i don't want to
over dramatize this it might just be
like i
do not like cats i think cats are evil
and i think cats are one of the worst
animals ever created and i know that
people are going to send
mean mean emails to me about cats cats
are perfect
they're not they're gross creatures
there's no reason to have a cat
um and i know just send all the mean
letters everybody
but my wife knows that too
and so i've been honest with her she's
not a cat fan either
but she's indifferent about them if i
felt like i really needed a cat
we'd have a cat um they make my eyes
itch
but we have grown-up talks about it and
so i don't want to over dramatize this
in just because if my wife came in with
three cats tomorrow and she's like hey
by the way we're having cats i'd have a
problem with it cause it'd make me sick
i don't i don't i wouldn't like it i
don't want to spend money on that etc
and so is it that or like i say is this
is there something else with your
marriage because if you can't have a
civil conversation
in marriage 2 at 50 years old about a
dog
my gut tells me there's something else
going on i think there is something
else i recently found out and this was
because he didn't admit it to me
i think there's been some type of abuse
as a child
okay that he experienced yes okay
and and i said well do you want
to talk about it and he was just like no
no sure
um so
well here's the thing
abuse is hard and it's hard to talk
about
it's hard to experience especially if
you're older and it's kind of woven into
the
your patterns but with you which you
interact with the world
and i also understand it can feel like
someone's holding back from you or not
being honest with you or not talking
about things with you
when you find out that someone you love
has had trauma in their life and they
don't want to talk about it it feels
personal
like they're they're holding out on you
and so i want you to not think of trauma
that way
i want you to not think of his responses
that way
and instead i want you to create a space
where he feels
loved and he feels valued
and that he feels like you're
all in with him and those things create
an environment or an atmosphere
where at some point he may feel
comfortable speaking those things out
into existence
and it's less about holding back from
you but for some folks
especially older men when they start
talking about historical trauma
abuse as a child they are waking dragons
that
they don't have the tools to slay they
don't have
the relationships they don't have other
men in their lives they're going to sit
with them and hug them while they weep
uncontrollably
they don't know how to go to counseling
or they've been told for 20 years that
or 30 years or 40 years people who go to
counseling are wimps and broken weirdos
they don't have church resources or
worse church says
just pray it away and it goes away just
get over yourself
if you really believed in fill in the
blank then you'd get over it
right and so it is less about him
holding out on you
and more about man if he opens that box
um
he feels like he's gone drowned and that
is a wound that has been there since he
was a little kid
and that is a wound that can only be
healed with
an environment where he feels safe safe
safe
and if you're fighting over a dog that's
not there's something else going on
there
right if you're thinking about my
marriage is in trouble i think was what
you said
uh man there are bigger things at play
here
and so would he go see somebody would he
go talk to somebody and go see a
counselor
uh i suggested marriage counseling he
doesn't believe in it
uh talking to the phone okay i'm sorry i
suggested marriage counseling and he
does not believe in that okay
um and i will suggest that he talks to a
counselor but i don't i don't know if he
would go
okay can you go take care of the things
because
you're you're a part of this too you're
with him too
you said i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
do this again i'm gonna get married
again and
um i'm gonna go all in on you i went all
in on somebody else before
it didn't work out i'm going all in on
you again and
i'm not going to lose this over a dog
right right he also is going to say i
don't want to lose this because of the
dog right so you you get this weird
impasse
but at some point i want you to work on
you so would
you be interested in going to see
somebody to
talk about ways that you can communicate
with somebody who may have experienced
trauma
that you can be somebody who can defuse
what sounds like a middle school
argument over a pet
right right and at the end of the day
all you can control is you
and at some point my hope is that you
begin to model for him
here's what communication looks like
here's what de-escalation looks like
like if he's about to pick a fight with
you you can say hey i love you i'm not
gonna fight with you over this
um i'm gonna go for a walk i love you
more than life itself
but we're not gonna do it no we're not
gonna fight over this this isn't worth
our marriage this isn't worth our
friendship
um and you're gonna learn some skills on
how to connect with somebody and maybe
they're skills you didn't pick up the
first time when you were married there
may skills that
that you haven't ever learned right but
at the end of the day that's all you can
focus on
are you worth investing in paula
yes i believe so i think you are i think
everybody
is worth investing in but especially you
and my hope is
that you learn some skills that you can
begin
begin to shift the kind of partner you
are and
create an ecosystem for him where he
feels safe and connected to
it's not fully your responsibility to
heal him you can't do that
but as a partner of somebody that you
love you can help create an environment
where he can feel safe and loved and
connected
and those are three words that a lot of
dudes don't use
safe loved and connected they use
achieved tough and snap into a slim jim
yeah let's lift weights
yeah let's play fantasy football where
we use other grown men as little
figurines
let's do that yeah you're going to
create a context where he feels safe
and loved and connected and then at that
point he might be able to heal
and then this dog dude this just sounds
like a red herring to me it just sounds
like a distraction from
a couple that needs to sit down and say
we love each other let's figure this out
and i'm going to work on me and i hope
you'll work on you